It would take Lucy 2 hours, and Javier 3 hours. Great thinking if you found
these numbers. We want to keep in mind that t represents the number of hours it
takes for Lucy to mow the yard alone. So when we solve for t in this equation,
we'll find Lucy's time. To begin solving this equation, we want to multiply
through by the LCD, which is 1 and 2 10ths times t times t plus 1. It's the
product of these 3 denominators since they're all different and the greatest
common factor is 1. When we multiply through by the LCD, we'll see that the
factors cancel. The t's will cancel. The quantity t plus 1 will reduce to 1.
And then number 1.2 or 1 and 2 10ths reduces to 1 as well. This leaves us with
1 and 2 10ths times t plus 1 here. 1 and 2 10th here and the quantity, t plus 1
times t here. We'll distribute the 1 and 2 10th and the t to the terms to get
this equation. Then we'll combine the like terms on the left hand side to get 2
and 4 10th times t, plus 1 and 2 10th equals t squared plus 2. To get rid of
these decimals, we'll multiply through by 10. So we'll have 24t plus 12 equals
10t squared plus 10t. Now we have a quadratic equation that we can try and
factor. We want to move all of these terms to the right hand side and then see
if we can factor. So, subtracting 24t and 12, we'll get 10t squared, minus 14t,
minus 12 on the right hand side of our equation. And we'll get 0 on the left. I
notice that all of these terms are even. So I can divide my entire equation by
2. 0 divided by 2 is 0. And then I divide each of these terms by 2. From this
quadratic equation, we use factoring by grouping to get the factors of 5t plus
3, and t minus 2. We set each of these factors equal to zero and then we solve
for the values of t. We find that t can equal positive 2, or t can equal
negative 3 5ths. We know that t represents the time for Lucy to mow the yard so
we don't want to use this negative value, it wouldn't make sense here. Instead,
we'll use t equals 2. So, she takes 2 hours to mow the yard. If we remember,
Javier's time was t plus 1, he took an hour longer than Lucy, so this would
mean he would mow the yard in 3 hours. We just needed to add 1 on to Lucy's
time.